unser bild vize paul ronzheimer ist
genau da wo es brennt in der hauptstand
in minsk seit einigen tagen paul wie ist
die lage bei den demonstranten der
opposition
wir sind schier unglaubliche szenen die
sich hier in minsk abspielen mehr als
100.000 menschen hier allein auf diesem
platz die gegen alexander lukaschenko
den diktator auf die straße gehen man
hört er soll gehen er soll gehen dass es
die forderung der demonstranten seit
vielen tagen seitens gewalt gegeben hat
aber so massive proteste wie heute hat
es hier noch nie gegeben und das obwohl
nur wenige stunden zuvor
lukaschenko selbst eine ansprache
gehalten hat ja lukaschenko hat sich
wieder gezeigt was bedeutet das genau
jetzt für die proteste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lukas schenkel hat vor seinen anhängern
die ja teilweise mit bussen offenbar an
karen lassen so muss man sagen aus
vorstädten wenige tausend menschen die
dort standen angeblich sollen sie sogar
bezahlt worden seien dafür dass sie am
ende für ihn demonstriert haben und dann
gab es den überraschenden auftritt von
lukaschenko der gesagt hat er will unter
allen umständen präsident bleiben koste
es was es wolle
er hat sogar gesagt wenn er tot sei
sinngemäß würde er das amt nicht abgeben
und er hat klare ansagen gemacht hier an
seine gegner dass er nicht bereit ist
abzutreten dass er nicht bereit ist das
amt abzugeben und das sorgt natürlich
auch hierfür diskussion darüber ob es
möglicherweise neue gewalt geben könnte
angewendet von lukaschenkos kräften aber
dass nach ihm gesehen haben heute am
heutigen tage zeigt eigentlich dass die
polizei ein so großes umfeld natürlich
nicht stürmen kann nur die menschen hier
sind friedlich wieder viele mit blumen
unterwegs mit rosen und sie zeigen wir
machen weiter wir wollen einen
friedlichen protest aber wir wissen auch
noch geschenke hat mit putin telefoniert
wie wird putin putin dann reagieren wie
schätzt du das 1
tatsächlich ist die offene frage hier
was vladimir putin tun wird der
russische präsident lukaschenko und auch
russland hat bekannt gegeben dass sie
erneut miteinander telefoniert haben
nach gestern also ein erneutes gespräch
zwischen beiden und es geht darum wie
russland hier möglicherweise zu den
verein am ende oder lässt putin lud
schenk so allein ist gut für beide
theorien beide möglichkeiten nennt die
sagen es kann passieren auch hier haben
wir mit demonstranten gesprochen die
tatsächlich angst davor haben dass putin
am ende hier herkommen könnte andere
sagen wir demonstrieren hier eben nicht
gegen russland es ist allein oder für
eine proeuropäische anwendung ist allein
hat protest gegen lukaschenko
es ist wirklich hoch spannend wie
entscheidend wird denn die nächste woche
werden die nächsten tage werden
entscheidend sein und viele sagen dass
schon morgen entscheidend sein könnte
wenn moden sollen erneut menschen
streichen als in den betrieben und da
wird sich dann noch ein schreiben wie es
wirtschaftlich weitergeht und wie lange
der protest durch das sagt unser bild
vize paul ronzheimer vor ort in minsk